tous
un après midi d'hiver
la première neige blanchit doucement la
ferme de monsieur dugarin on le ferme et
à penser au grain et au grain pour les
mésanges qui fréquentent l' affaire
elles ne sont pas les seuls car depuis
bien longtemps toutes sortes d'espèces
animales ont appris que les champs il
est maison de les hommes procure
nourriture et refuge mais les animaux ne
cesse pas pour autant d'être sauvage la
nuit dit en hiver monsieur dugué rhin
comme ses chiens ses chasses est
assouplie au coin du feu ni le labrador
sur canapé ni le fermier ne voient
passer le visiteur du soir
furtif est sacrément audacieux entre
rêve et veille ne fait rien pour
attendre un rat
qui douterait à chênois y avoue qu'elle
va en plus du calva célèbre dans tout le
village il est vrai pas étonnant qu'il
aime ça mais quand on est un rat et
qu'on s'adonne à la boisson ont fini par
à l'usiné c'est fou il est un rongeur
géant n'en a pas peur
un rat sain rouge de tous
le plastique de câbles de ses petit goût
sucré de toute façon parce qu'il ya la
paix mais monsieur de garein bien
d'accord avec le ral son rêve au lit la
longue nuit d'hiver hanté par la dame
blanche se pose sur la maison le fermier
s'endort comme les chats ne sont pas là
et que le maître des lieux se reposent
certains profitent la famille sourit a
fait son nid au bout d'un tunnel dans
une plainte du salon et c'est la nuit
que les souris dansent
il leur faut à chaque sortie des
dizaines de grammes de nourriture
tout y passe millette papier fils
électriques doublure de challans terre
et bien sûr dans la grande tradition
souris fromage
entre deux assauts à une ennuyeuse
cloche de verre un couple sourit fleurs
de gentiment le collègue louis moins
sentimentale à trouver l'entrée s'est
fiancé là cette nuit préfère les
calembours hier à il faut comprendre la
souris est un animal fragiles et sans
défense et en faisant beaucoup de petits
et souvent que le couple sourit assure
la survie de l'espèce
les nécessités de l'espèce n'attendent
pas et puis l'hiver les distractions
sont rares
ses amours disquette ne peuvent tiré de
son sommeil la brave labrador dit sauf à
qui pourtant chasse les souris en rêve
et c'est ainsi que l'hiver passe
jusqu'au réveil de la terre en ce petit
matin frisquet d'un printemps timide
monsieur dugarin a déjà fort à faire
entre porcherie et basques où l'eau
le rouge peu est tout aussi matinale il
commence sa journée bien avant le lever
du soleil le rouge-gorge s'approche des
maisons en hiver et rejoint les bois en
été monsieur dugarin c'est la différence
entre ces deux oiseaux mais les anciens
pensait que rouges gorges était une
métamorphose hivernale de rouge que sauf
à ces jeunes soeurs noires des côtes il
se réveille doucement
vaguement dérangés par le pépiement des
moineaux ceux là sont de très classique
moineaux le piaf en somme les premiers
animaux sauvages se côtoient les
habitants des villes se dit monsieur
dugarin et qu'on dit menacé de
disparition
il vit en colonie dans les
anfractuosités du toit lemoine ou est
infidèle sa courte vie de trois ou
quatre ans il la passe à l'endroit où il
a nichées une première fois jeudi qu'il
vit en couple uni pour la vie que ce
scout
pour avoir jusqu'à trois couverts en n
était qu il faut ce qu'il faut
le couple garnira ensuite son nid de
poils de plumes et de débris de toutes
sortes et il y restera en brave
sédentaire il vient suivant tous les
petits oiseaux de la catégorie
passereaux sont en quête de matériaux
d'aménagement à tout peut servir avec
une nette préférence pour le mouël des
plumes et la douceur des poils de chien
tout ce que les labradors leur abandonne
fait l'objet d'une rude concurrence
le noble compagnon de l'homme étant
absorbée par les joies de la baguette
industrielle le chardonneret en profite
pour bâtir sans être dérangé celui ci
est dit chardonneret élégant un petit
festival de couleurs qui anime le sapin
chez un labrador gourmand le pain perdu
on connaît pas
l'heure du déjeuner a sonné pour tous
les gardiens de la maison chat noir et
jaar où sont au régime boulette ceux qui
ne présentent aucune garantie que leur
instinct de chasseur aurait disparu le
labrador sans même les chats le tolère
il le gratifierait même d'une sortes
d'affections tient remarque monsieur
dugarin la coquine et lomnitsa fugain
dans la remise la femelle rouge-gorge
chauffe ses 5 e
un peu choqué que le fermier cegid si
bruyamment quant aux troubles audit il
nourrissait oisivement c'est sa manière
de travailler du chapeau le plafond et
les poutres de la remise sont le domaine
de la grande migratrices la voyageuse
les rondelles de chemini est déjà revenu
d'afrique et pour construire son nid
elle fait au moins 120 kilomètres
d'allées et venues entre la remise et la
mare où elle prend de quoi accumuler un
bon millier de boules est debout et
entre la remise et les champs où elle
ramasse l'herbe sèche qui conforte le
mortier un mois de travail pour une
construction remarquable de solidité et
de sens architectural rien à voir avec
le prête à vivre du faucon crécerelle
que madame ne se donne pas la peine
il suffit d'attendre qu'un mâle se
présente
la première des deux niches et du rouge
gorge est arrivé l'oiseau fait des
norias d'asticots avec sa niche et il a
trouvé une réserve
monsieur dugarin est un pécheur
distraite les petits rouges gorges sont
nés tout nu et tout fragile avant même
d'ouvrir les yeux il ouvre le bec
dès qu'ils sentent les vibrations que
produit le retour d'un parent honni le
rouge vif des gosiers ouvert et pour les
parents un signal visuel d'une
indiscutable précision la dame pour
qu'on n'a pas eu longtemps un temps
devoir accompli le partenaire repart à
la chasse et la femelle s'apprête pour
la niche et de printemps
cette fois c'est clair la coquine à un
cocktail le labrador du voisin les
préliminaires sont rapides ne passage à
l'apd est maladroit c'est la fougue de
la passion
quand on pense qu autrefois se dit
monsieur dugarin ont leur jetaient des
seaux d'eau pour préserver l'innocence
des jeunes filles dans la prairie qui
sent déjà l'été les paisibles vaches
salers contribuer comme toujours au
ravitaillement des étourneaux
ils les oiseaux se régale des insectes
qui les entoure et des verts que leur
passage des terres il faut dire que eux
aussi ont déniché à nourrir certains ont
élu domicile entre deux pierres les
oisillons grandissent vite et font
mentir comme toujours l'expression
appétit d'oiseau
le rouge-gorge continue sa collec pour
les grands bousiller qui réclame sans
discontinuer le pêcheur a peu fait
exprès de ne pas ranger son matériel
les parents rouge gorge ce relais non
seulement pour le ravitaillement mais
aussi pour l'évacuation des déchets les
crottes se présente un petite poche
souple que les adultes en porte pour les
jeter n'importe où les allers retours se
font en garde un oeil sur les familiers
de la maison quand on est oiseaux chez
un ami déjà on n'est jamais trop prudent
le ch a beau être feliz domestiques us
s'est quand même fait l'un un chasseur
le cousin du lynx aux yeux d'or raffole
des petites proies qui s'agitent sous
les grilles
monsieur du gard un regard de chat roux
repartir à la chasse le chat est bien
resté un animal sauvage
il consent à cohabiter avec l'homme mais
s'il le fallait il reprendrait vite ses
habitudes dans les forêts
le vent qui se lève annonce la pluie et
bouscule les parures de plumes
les animaux se mettent à l'abri
là le félin revient bredouille aimiez
monsieur dugarin c'est que charroux et
très sexy qu'il va faire une longue
toilettes pour encaisser c'est
intolérable humiliation
quand une nuit humide et fraîche tombe
sur la maison indiscrets visiteurs
passent le nez le hérisson a sorti de
son hibernation et profite du crépuscule
pour partir en quête de nourriture
la maison s'endort monsieur dugarin se
demande juste avant de s'endormir
s'il a bien pensé à tout comme
d'habitude la chienne sofa veille
intensément
les petits doigts adhésif du rat noir
sont bien commodes pour grimper partout
pour s'accrocher pour monter et
descendre sur toutes les surfaces
tout est intéressant pour un rat noir
il lui arrive même de rouge et la brique
ou le béton alors penser la réserve des
pistons et puis le rapport c'est un
malin il sait que le chien dit de garde
ne bougera pas
l'heure de la radiant a sonné toute la
bande passe de l'attaqué on en boit
après on se nettoie un plus et on
recommence
la nuit est aussi le royaume de la
chouette effraie la dame blanche
fantômes des greniers la douceur de son
plumage rançon vole presque complètement
silencieux dans son lit monsieur du gard
un cauchemar les souris s'y sont mises
en réserve et pillé au matin et rongeurs
n'auront laissé pour tout indice de leur
passage ravageur que quelques minces
traces de poussière
un coup de peigne avec les griffes et on
y retourne
la souris comme le rat m à prendre soin
de sa fourrure ce n'est pas parce qu'on
laisse des crottes partout qu'on a
négligé le lendemain matin comme
toujours le fermi a commencé sa journée
par la basse cour il est passé nettoyer
le clapier
mais il a dû faire une visite à la
cuisine en entendant des petits cris le
résultat des oeuvres du labrador voisin
est arrivé dans la nuit
ils sont sept d'un coup les lois de la
génétique ont opéré des noirs et des
blancs tous labrador un jeu d'échecs
livre affamés presser les yeux fermés
mais la gueule prête à partir à la
conquête des techniquement
cette touchante cette de famille ne fait
ni chaud ni froid chat noir
il se concentre feliz le félin surveille
les petites proies volante qui le nargue
les anges bleus se déchaînent en parade
amoureuse comme si elle sentait que le
réduit étant fermées et impuissant pire
encore elle semble s'amuser de leur
propre reflet ça frôle résulte une
humiliation de ce genre exige chez un
chat une compensation immédiate
chat noir pourrait se faire une toile
est née cette fois il choisit le
rapprochement avec la chienne lille a
frôlé pour l'intégrer une fois encore à
son territoire à l'us il accepte même
une petite sieste jouer sans sa
compagnie enfin elle est quand même bien
maladroite mauvaise journée sur la
terrasse le mérule noir s'affairent y
est aussi familier de la maison que le
moineau vers de terre 1 cette grêle il
gobe de tous c'est un maître dans l'art
de contrôle et l'élasticité du lombric
mais la saison exige qu'ils nourrissent
une petite
enfin petit si on peut dire sa
progéniture est presque aussi grosses
que lui et fort exigeante
monsieur dugarin vient à peine de donner
sa patte et la famille chiens qu'ils
remarquent dans la prairie une curieuse
rencontre
la jument comtoise croiser le monde
sauvage en la personne colérique d'un
superbe le héron cendré les barrières
des hommes n'ont pas de sens pour les
animaux
c'est l'heure où passe le facteur le
fermier est sorti à sa rencontre parce
que l'idée le début du printemps il à
renoncer à un usage de sa boîte aux
lettres à la maison charbonnier calotte
noire et javaux blanc se l'est approprié
pour lui ne sait de couver de l'année
les parents veilleront sur l'ours
oisillons jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient leurs
costumes de plumes complet à mésanges se
pose rarement au sol de ses paires choix
elle quelques instituts et elles
surveillent la proche des filles chat
noir une revanche à prendre
la revanche ce sera sur le maître sont
un peu des manières de chiens mais bon
la maison j'en profite pour rapporter
audi graines du jeudi destiné à sa
collection de gosier insatiable
comme le rouge gorge elle veille à la
propreté des lieux
on évacue en aide aux schafroth une
locataire modèle certes le maître l'a
défendu mais les mirabelles
c'est tout aussi irrésistible qu'un gros
steak
le ch est carnivore c'est vrai mais
n'est mirabel c'est supprimer
chez les hirondelles comme celle au
merle les petits sont désormais d'une
taille impressionnante et les parents se
relaient toujours pourchassés
infatigablement pendant ce temps la
bande des rats a gagné en impudence la
tap
au grenier se fait en plein jour le rat
noir et végétariens les amateurs de
grenier ou le confondant la répulsion
avec son parent leur agri dix rats
d'égouts le surmulot venu des steppes il
ya trois siècles a chassé le rat noir de
ces territoires des villes
toujours est il que notre race noire lui
serait venue de l'inde nous est
lointaine contre il a voyagé jusqu'à
nous de grenier en réserve en rangeant
dévorant en soulignant de poils et de
crottes les récoltes et les garde manger
avec le temps le rat noir sert
remarquablement adaptée à l'évolution
des matériaux inventée par l'homme
pour finir on se lèche dans une grosse
le ventre qui ramassent la poussière
quand on vous dit que le rail soigner
les fleurs de l'été attire au jardin les
butineurs
il
gaiffe ces hommes vivent ensemble depuis
les temps les plus reculés
les uns se tenant à l'écart des piqûres
d autres monsieur du gard à repérer les
nids de guêpes pauliste installé sous
presque chaque tuiles du toit
la guêpe pauliste doit son nom aux grecs
police qui signifie cité l'insecte est
connu pour son talent de bâtisseur une
femelle a initié la construction d'un
ensemble de cellules hexagonal fait de
végétaux broyés de salive et orienté
vers le bas pour empêcher la pluie d'y
pénétrer
le hérisson solitaire et in ils se
promènent rarement le jour et il part
quelques l'odeur alléchés
chat noir et charron en bon félins ont
coutume de laisser des restes dans
l'heure actuelle pour aller le digérer à
l'aise avant d'y retourner
hérisson un gros enjeu de l'image de
chimie et de serpents les croquettes
achat lui rappelle t-elle un goût qui
lui plaît avant de passer à table il y
son manteau pour se défaire de ses
nombreuses puces le hérisson en prend
son temps et s'il est menacée il lui
suffira de se mettre en boule et
d'opposer à l'agresseur les similitudes
quant à céret de son dos monsieur
ducarin a lu quelque part qu'à la
renaissance le hérisson est tu es un des
symboles du toucher enfin avant ça les
anciens avaient vu en lui une
incarnation de la gourmandise
sous l'oeil un peu défi de leur tante du
flou en noir et blanc commence à
regarder le monde et ils ont déjà l'air
de s'en plaindre rêvent-ils déjà de
chasse en course une bagarre rêve telle
qu'elle aussi a des petits à cet âge là
portée de chiots ne se réveille vraiment
pour tt chacun à la place qu'il a
conquise
là
le couple de faucons crécerelles lui
doit chasser pour ravitailler ces niches
et il semble prendre la pose comme les
faucons du moyen âge au point des nobles
dames qui allait à la chasse tactique
duguay repérer la souris ou le campagnol
imprudent ensuite survolé la proie
puis ajuster la tacc parent sur place
dix vols en saint-esprit au bon moment
frappée en piqué et le choc et le coup
de bec qui l'accompagnent sont presque
toujours mans
o'neill et fauconneau ont grandi gris
gros velud brasse le couple chasse sans
relâche démonstration s'il en était
besoin que la fécondité record des
souris et autres mulot est leur seul
défaut les faucons crécerelles son
meilleur preneur de campagnols que
chasseurs d'oiseaux sauf dans les villes
où ils comptent volontiers sur les
petits moineaux
le faucon de monsieur dugarin comme tout
mais crécerelle s'accommode des humains
avec plus de facilité que d'autres
espèces de la noble famille
la tombée de la nuit donne toujours de
l'audace aux visiteurs sauvage m
blaireau fait une visite au grain de la
basse cour il n'empêche pas monsieur du
gard de s'endormir paisiblement le
fermière enfin pensez à acheter de quoi
décourager la bande des rats noirs
il a toute confiance dans la tapette à
l'ancienne moins risqués que les grains
empoisonné et moins cher
oui
vous
e
encouragées sans doute par cette grande
victoire sur la technologie les rats se
sentent tout permis
il est charmant de déguster un encas
nocturne au rythme d'une valse à avoir
souviennent l'impératrice sissi
c'est l'idole du chine
pendant ce temps le blanc fantôme fidèle
à la maison depuis quinze ans est à
l'affût
les petits l'attendent
ils ont quatre semaines et le visage
caractéristiques des chouettes effraies
c'est un membre de la famille sourit qui
fait les frais de l'appétit des
chouettes ont ils sont nourris de cette
manière pendant pas moins de deux mois
chez les souris c'est le grand soir
les naissances y sont spectaculaires pas
moins de 10 porté de cinq à sept
sourisseau parents les souriceaux
naissent et grandissent dans le nid que
leur préparent leur mère elle cherche
pour le faire un endroit sur un trou
sous le plancher dans un mur à quoi
oublier est retiré
je
les souriceaux sang tan l'été pendant 18
jours avant de vivre leur vie tout
petits le souriceau prend déjà soin de
son pelage
il brosse à il sage et ses chats du
crépuscule à l'aube les parents chouette
fondé dizaine d'allers retours avec leur
territoire de chasse
gavé de rougeurs ébouriffés les petits
sont presque aussi gros que leurs
parents
la chouette voit plus clair que nous de
jour comme de nuit
ses yeux sont cent fois plus sensible
que les nôtres
ces serres puissante tu la proie sur le
coup elle engloutit sa victime puis
régurgite les parties indigeste comme le
poil ou les eaux
les souris de la maison sont à l'abri du
rapace nocturne toute la bande explore
une véritable mine bronzée heures
monsieur dugarin constatera au matin
qu'elle dévore littéralement de
l'information les souriceaux s'entraîne
à l' usage de leur pâte collante leurs
exercices d'équilibré leur serviront
quand ils partiront à l'assaut des
parois glissant de bocaux de boîte de
poudre
les souris java partout mercerie nettoie
ses outils pour qu'ils restent secs et
chauds et les roms et rooney et quand il
s'égare un peu trop les petites
chouettes jusqu'au matin souffle comme
des charentes colère impitoyable et
renvoient leurs parents à la chasse
encore et encore
les matins se sont fait plus frais
vous
ce
il faut que nous en grand dit il sans
son premier essai en vol
les chiots eux en sont aux premières
aventures
le jeu d'échecs à pattes dans une sortie
j'ai du garun se félicite du remarquable
et fait 101 dalmatiens nous applique
trouve regretté de deux vallées laisser
partir chez les voisins qui les ont
depuis longtemps réservés
les jeunes chiens eux n'ont qu'une hâte
se mettre en route pour les premières
bêtises et en avant pour les premiers
des gares où la porte est promu
les petits chiens s'endorment
enfin elle maîtrise heureusement l'art
de la sieste aussi bien que leur tante
labrador blanc reste il a un été sans
fin
à
les brouillards d'automne estompe les
couleurs y glisse un vent froid dans les
branches
le pinson qui profitait de la mangeoire
des mésanges se retrouve en cage chien
et chat jouait très ni c'est pour mieux
se retrouver au coin du feu
la terre va s'endormir sous une nouvelle
n'est ce monsieur dugarin vérifie que
tout est prêt pour les oiseaux fidèles
mais change et moi nos familles
quand le chat n'est pas là quand les
hommes sont d'ors la bande des rats
passe un nouveau chapitre de son éternel
exploration si on essayait les yeux